Thank you for being a part of this exciting event.
Liberty Military Housing is a leading provider of U.S. military housing.
We are so happy to have them here.
Everybody clap your hands. Clap, clap, clap, clap your hands.
Alright now, we're going to motivate you to step to the left.
Take it back now, yeah.
One, up this table.
Right foot, left step.
Left foot, left step.
Now it's time to get funky.
To the right now.
To the left.
Take it back now, yeah.
One, up this table.
Right foot, two arms.
Left foot, two arms.
Slide to the left.
Slide to the right.
Chris Brown.
Jump, jump, real sweet.
Yeah.
To the left.
Take it back now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
To the left together.
Very good, very good.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Hey, yo.
Hey there.
Yo.
Penalty to all doors.
Oh, yeah, the littlest one.
Power would go around.